>> IT'S FRIDAY!
THAT MEANS IT'S TIME FOR DAN
BONGINO'S NEWS EXPLOSION.
THIS WEEK, THE THEME, OF COURSE,
THE MUELLER REPORT.
THE FAVORITE NEW YORK CITY COP
AND SECRET SERVICE AGENT IS HERE
TO GIVE US HIS TAKEAWAYS.
AS YOU LISTEN TO WHAT HE SAYS,
SEE IF YOU CATCH HIM USING THE
WORD "UM" OR "HMM" OR PAUSING AT
ALL.
HE'S THE MOST COMPLETE SENTENCE
SPEAKER YOU'VE SEEN IN YOUR
ENTIRE LIFE.
>> NO PROMPTER EITHER.
NOT EVEN PUTTING NOTES ON MY
HAND.
THIS IS ALL NATCH EURO.
-- NATURAL.
STORY NUMBER THREE, I HAVE TO GO
BACK TO CPL.
FRANK IN CNN, A CREATION OF CNN.
THE MORE WE FIND OUT ABOUT THIS
GUY, THE MORE -- THE CREEPY HE
BECOMES.
IT'S AMAZING.
TUCKER HAS THERE EVER BEEN A
LESS IMPRESSIVE HUMAN BEING ON
CABLE NEWS OPINING ON A WIDER
BREADTH OF TOPICS?
>> Tucker: THAT'S SAYING A LOT,
AS YOU KNOW.
>> HE WAS ON THIS SHOW CALLED
"RELIABLE SOURCES" THAT'S THE
FUNNIEST PART OF THIS WHOLE
THING.
LIKE, LISTEN, BRIAN STEALTHER
CHANGED THE TITLE OF THE SHOW.
HIS CLIPS WEREN'T GOING
ANYWHERE.
UNRELIABLE SOURCES.
>> GOT TO BE AT BEST.
YOU CAN'T GO BACK TO THAT.
THAT SHIP HAS SAILED.
>> STORY NUMBER TWO, GETTING
BACK TO THE MUELLER REPORT.
THE CRITICAL, CRITICAL TAKEAWAY.
IT'S NOT WHAT WAS IN THE MUELLER
REPORT THAT FASCINATED ME.
AND I'M THROUGH ABOUT 90% OF IT.
GOT TO GET THROUGH THE GRU
STUFF.
IT'S NOT WHAT'S NOT IN IT.
TUCKER, WE'VE BEEN TOLD BY THE
BRILLIANT ACADEMICS AND MEDIA
PEOPLE OUT THERE WHO AS YOU KNOW
ARE MUCH SMARTER THAN YOU AND I.
WE'RE THE
IT STORY NUMBER ONE.
HOW DID THEY BLOW THIS?
THE AMERICAN MEDIA WAS
COMPLETELY HUMILIATED, TUCKER.
THEY GOT THE STORY TOTALLY
BACKWARDS FROM THE START.
THEY TOLD US COLLUSION WAS REAL.
THE SPY SCANDAL WAS FAKE.
WE'RE CONSPIRACY THEORISTS.
THE SPYING SCANDAL WAS REAL AND
COLLUSION WAS FAKE.
I FIND IT IRONIC THEY KEEP
PATTING THEMSELVES ON THE BACKS
FOR GETTING MINOR DETAILS RIGHT.
IT'S LIKE GOING TO THE BANK
ROBBERY, REPORTING ON A BANK  HA
ROBBERY, REPORTING ON A BANK  HP
ROBBERY, REPORTING ON A BANK  HN
ROBBERY, REPORTING ON A BANK  HD
ROBBERY, REPORTING ON A BANK  H.
>> Tucker: BY THE WAY, THIS SHOW
DID GET IT RIGHT FROM DAY ONE.
WE PATTED OURSELVES ON THE BACK
A SINGLE TIME.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO NOW.